The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so a couple
really quick announcements--
on Monday, I mentioned a
number of other classes
that are offered in the spring
if you're interested in game
development here at MIT.
But I forgot this one.
This is 11.127.
It's also cross-listed
as CMS.590.
It's taught by Eric Klopfer
and Scott Osterweil.
Scott should be in
our class next Monday,
I believe, to talk to
us about learning games.
But if you end up
being interested
in games for learning,
games for education,
this is a great class to take.
And it's offered in the spring.
We also have a class, CMS.615,
Games for Social Change,
that's being taught this fall.
So if the topics of the
games that we're working on
for Project 4 are
something that you just
find yourself really interested
in in the next couple years,
those are two classes you can
take to explore that further.
PHILIP TAN: All right,
so I guess for me, it's
talking for an hour, and then
after that, teamwork, right?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
PHILIP TAN: OK, so today,
what we're going to do
is talk a little bit about
aesthetics, about what we
mean when we say
we want your game
to have a cohesive aesthetic.
We do realize that the games
that we're asking you to make
are extremely time constrained.
We've been asking you not to go
terribly much beyond the scope
of what you've done before.
But what we want
to see in your game
is a really, really
cohesive aesthetic.
We used to tell
students that we wanted
them to put out polished games.
But there was a really
unclear definition
when we used to do this about
what a polished game would be.
And we also realized
that for some students,
for a lot of you, you've seen
games that are really, really,
really polished.
When I say a polished
game, can you
come up with some
examples of things
that immediately come to mind?
STUDENT: Limbo.
PHILIP TAN: Limbo?
Yeah, that's the
black and white side
scrolling platform, really,
really spooky, gorgeous visuals
and sound design.
What else?
Yeah.
STUDENT: All of the
Final Fantasy games
have really polished UIs.
PHILIP TAN: Pretty much, yeah.
Every single Final
Fantasy game for its era
is probably like the high
watermark for production
values-- not just the UI.
But you're right in
saying the UI is alive.
Whenever you even switch
to a different menu option,
it does this little animation.
STUDENT: It's one of the
only [INAUDIBLE] that
has a really good UI design.
And I've looked at
a bunch of them.
And it's like, Final
Fantasy is just way
better than all that stuff.
And of course,
the graphics, too.
PHILIP TAN: Which is amazing,
because they change it
so much every game.
Unlike a lot of
other franchises,
they change the formula
a lot, but also of course
other things, like
the animation quality
and the music and
the voice act--
maybe not the voice acting.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Meat Boy.
PHILIP TAN: Super Meat Boy?
STUDENT: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] physics.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, for folks
who haven't played this game,
it's a really punishing game.
But it makes it super
easy for you to try again.
In fact, there's like a
single frame between you dying
and you starting the game again.
And it goes right off.
A game built by two people, by
the way-- it's an indie game.
You can see it in documentaries
like Indie Game-- The Movie.
And you can see even though
they're working on their own--
and they do spend a
considerable amount of time
on an extremely visually
polished and musically amazing
game as well.
STUDENT: Monument Valley
PHILIP TAN: Monument
Valley for the iOS?
Yeah, I can't remember, has
it come out for Android yet?
But it's definitely
iOS right now.
But what strikes
you as polished?
STUDENT: The graphics and the
gameplay is just very smooth.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm,
and the game's kind
of like a flat shaded
isometric game,
if you're familiar
with that 3D concept.
It means that things
that are far away
are the same size as things
that are close to you--
isometric orthogonal projection.
The camera is kind of looking at
the world at a 45 degree angle
up and sideways.
Everything's flat shaded, but
it's got incredible art design.
It's got art direction,
I would say, just
how all of the characters,
even though they basically all
have one color, maybe
black and white,
move with a lot
of expressiveness.
They have iconic characters,
and you immediately
sort of recognize what each
character is supposed to be,
even though the game
is pretty much made out
of geometric shapes.
I call out Hearthstone.
Anyone playing that?
Anyone else?
Yeah, it's like just every
little bit of movement
that the screen does as
soon as your finger touches
that screen is amazing.
Even little silly
things, like when
you are looking for
a match, and you
see all the other
people who you could
have been matched against.
And it of course always selects
the perfect match for you.
It's a ridiculous
little UI thing.
But it sort of gets
you in the mood.
And of course, that's
like music and stuff
for what's really a card game,
a collectible card game, right?
So what I'd like to do right
now is play through a game
that I feel has a
coherent aesthetic.
But maybe you wouldn't
necessarily call it polished.
But it gets you a
little bit closer
to what we're looking at.
Because it might be a little bit
more feasible for this class.
So who hasn't played Sissy's
Magical Ponycorn Adventure yet?
Who would like to, actually?
All the hands went up.
Come on down, yeah, you, yeah.
OK.
SISSY: Sissy's Magical
Ponycorn Adventure.
PHILIP TAN: Is that too loud?
Is that OK?
SISSY: Hi, my name is Sissy.
And I simply love ponycorns.
It is the best
thing in the world,
because it's a pony and unicorn.
It's a ponycorn.
I don't have any
ponycorns right now,
so I'm going to go get some.
Come with me on my magical
ponycorn adventure.
I can go through rainbows
to visit new places.
That's not a ponycorn. it's a
goat on a pole. [INAUDIBLE].
Hi, Orange Boy,
my name is Sissy.
ORANGE BOY: [GIBBERISH]
SISSY: Do you like ponycorns?
SISSY: Me too.
Got any jars?
ORANGE BOY: [GIBBERISH]
SISSY: Thanks.
If I find any ponycorns,
I'll put them in these jars.
This is an empty jar
for holding ponycorns.
I see a new rainbow.
EVIL LEMON: [CACKLING]
I'm an evil lemon.
SISSY: [INAUDIBLE]
EVIL LEMON: I will squirt
lemon juice in your eyes,
and that stings.
SISSY: Oh no, what will I do?
EVIL LEMON: Stay away.
SISSY: [SCREAMS]
SISSY: [SCREAMS] I found a key.
Hmm, this [INAUDIBLE].
TIGER: Hi, I am a tiger,
and I'm going to eat you.
SISSY: No you're not.
TIGER: Yes I am.
SISSY: [SCREAMS]
TIGER: I'm going to
eat that ponycorn.
SISSY: I got a coconut.
It's a coconut.
I'm going to throw this
coconut at you, lemon.
EVIL LEMON: Oh no.
Ow, my face.
SISSY: That's what you get
for being evil and a lemon.
EVIL LEMON: Stay away.
SISSY: [SCREAMS]
PHILIP TAN: Oh, I think you
might have broken the game,
but that's cool.
STUDENT: What about a jar?
PHILIP TAN: Oh, jar, yeah, try.
SISSY: This is an empty jar.
I got the green ponycorn.
I put it in the jar.
PHILIP TAN: OK, all
right, so I think everyone
gets the idea of the game.
Thank you so much.
Yay, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So let me actually switch
to my presentation.
There we go.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about aesthetics.
Now, what about that
game seemed off?
Let's start with, what in
the game seems out of place?
STUDENT: The artwork, I guess?
PHILIP TAN: The artwork
seems out of place?
Out of place
compared to the-- it
is a bit of a trick question.
I have trouble figuring
out what's out of place.
I think maybe the
cursor hand actually
looks like this default
kind of browser cursor hand,
is the one thing that
I feel is not really
cohesive of everything else.
The artwork kind
of sets the tone,
is pretty much the first
thing that you see.
Even before you start
playing the game,
you see the artwork
and the website.
And then of course,
when the music comes on,
you actually hear pretty
much the girl's voice
for most of the game.
You get to about
halfway through the game
before you hear a
dad's voice playing
the lemon and Orange Boy, I
guess-- wah, wah, wah, wah.
Did anyone notice
the user interface?
STUDENT: It's not obvious at
first what's clickable and what
isn't.
An outline could maybe
help or something
when you hover over something
that you can actually click.
PHILIP TAN: What are any visual
cues that you were working off
to figure out what to click on?
STUDENT: Things would be drawn
on different pieces of paper.
That wasn't clear.
But in general,
clicking on everything
is just what I do normally
in point and click games.
PHILIP TAN: It is
a click everything
in the game kind of game.
So that makes sense.
There is actually
a slight little bit
of drop shadow behind
everything that you can click.
And some things that
you can click but
don't do anything, like the
goat on the stick, for instance.
I thought I saw
another hand over here
about the user interface.
Anyone?
STUDENT: I was going to
say the drop shadows.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, OK,
the drop shadows, yeah.
Yeah.
STUDENT: I don't
think there's always
a drop shadow between
everything you can click on.
Because I'm pretty sure you
can click on the cactus,
and the cactus has
no drop shadow.
PHILIP TAN: Oh, OK.
STUDENT: She's like, ow, cactus.
And I was like,
oh, that's weird.
That didn't give
me any indication
that collecting it would
give some sort of feedback.
PHILIP TAN: I forget, does
the cactus do anything?
STUDENT: Uh-uh.
PHILIP TAN: Ah, so I think
there is a big difference, then.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] cactus.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
everything that's
like crucial to advance
in the game I notice
has a drop shadow.
But yeah, if you
click everywhere
in the world-- if it looks like
something that might stand out
from the blank sheet of paper,
it should respond, right?
So even though the
cactus is not sort
of a crucial piece of
the plot, such as it is,
it is something that a
player might reasonably
expect to be able to
click on and do something.
And yeah, you get pricked by it.
She says, ow.
There's some voice.
And there's a little
bit of payoff on that.
Every time he clicks, there's
a little blue crayon circle
that sort of emanates from
where you're clicking.
So there's another little
typical UI feedback
of, all right, you
clicked on this thing,
and we're acknowledging
your mouse click,
but we're going
to do it in a way
that sort of works with
the rest of the art style.
I think something else that
also stands out a little bit
is-- let me see.
If I go back to the game--
oh, I closed it, didn't I?
OK, all right, does
anyone remember
if the border between the
game space and the inventory,
was that like a
straight line, or was
that kind of a raggedy thing?
I thing it's pure
straight line, right?
Yeah, so that's
another weird thing.
It's like, this is a
game that's made out
of like ripped sheets of paper.
Then all of a sudden,
there's this hard white line
right across.
What works in this game?
Why would someone
want to play this
to the end-- which just
takes about five minutes.
It's not terribly long.
STUDENT: It's sort
of all whimsical.
And you kind of want to find
out what this girl came up with,
and what they worked together
to create, basically.
The story behind the creation
of the game is also interesting.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
it's father/daughter,
but the daughter led the
project, basically determined
how everything
was going to work.
The dad just did the
coding and some voices,
of course scanning,
and things like that.
But very quickly,
you're introduced things
like the goat on the stick.
Very, very quickly, it just
establishes that you're just
playing in five-year-old
logic right now,
and this whole world is
going to work that way.
The fact that it's
narrated largely
by this character-- who has an
opening cut scene, actually.
It's just like, I'm Sissy,
and I fricking love ponycorns,
and then explains
what a ponycorn is.
And then you don't actually
get to see one until pretty far
into the game.
But as soon as you're told,
yes, that lump of green
is a ponycorn, is a pony
with a unicorn horn,
you then say, OK, all
right, that's a ponycorn.
That's something I want.
And at that point
in time, you already
know you're supposed
to put them in jars.
So that starts to
talk about something
that we've already been
exploring a lot in this class.
It's kind of like the
systemic aesthetic, how
a person feels when they're
playing through a set of rules.
And Sissy's Magical
Ponycorn Adventure,
it's the set of rules as
devised by a five-year-old.
But they're actually all
internally consistent.
When you play through
the whole game,
you start to figure
out, yeah, clicking
everywhere is actually a
perfectly reasonable strategy.
Because nothing's really going
to hurt you in this game.
You may get scared.
You may get pricked by a cactus.
But nothing's really
going to hurt you.
So it's OK to click
on everything.
And the kinds of decisions
that you get to make
are more like, is
now the right time
to use to jar on a ponycorn?
Do I need to do
something first to get
past the lemon or the other
bad folks who get in your way?
And the kinds of
rules and strategies
that you have to devise
to be able to navigate
through your space
gives you a certain kind
of systemic aesthetic.
And you've been working with
that since the beginning
of the semester.
Prototyping-- some of
you have made games
that make you feel very tense.
Some of the games
are more zen-like.
Some games are more strategic.
And you have to
really think carefully
about your next decision.
And some of them
are kind of frantic.
And those have all
come out from the rules
that you devised first
on your prototypes.
And then you moved them over
to your digital versions.
And that's one
form of aesthetic.
But then there's also the
other kind of aesthetic
that we've been talking a
little bit when we talked about
polish-- the art
direction, the music, how
a 3D object is
rendered, or even how
a 2D graphic is represented.
Is it drawn in crayon, or
is it high quality line art,
or is it something running
in the Crytek engine,
and you've got mobile
mapping and specular lighting
and things look like fire
and glass and concrete?
Do the sound effects
sound like they're coming
from a place in the world?
Do they sound like the thing
they're supposed to sound like?
Do they sound other worldly
or little MIDI notes,
the sort of thing that you would
expect from a Nintendo game,
from an old school
Nintendo game?
And then there's the things
that we would normally
refer to as sort of
the story of the game.
There's the plot of what happens
to characters as they navigate
through the world, and who are
these characters, who are they
really, and what sort of
emotional development they're
going to go through.
What's the theme of the game?
Is it a game about being
isolated from everybody else?
Is it a game about
US military strength?
I think the theme of
Call of Duty is actually,
America starts wars,
England finishes them,
which is kind of weird
if you look at history.
And where is this game set?
When is this game set?
Hopefully that's clear enough.
And I think one of the
things that can help
is just a little
bit of vocabulary
so that when you're talking
in your team about what's
working in your
aesthetic, it helps
to be able to put words to it
so that people can understand
what part of the aesthetic
that you're talking about.
Are you talking
about the things that
have to do with a game
system, your rules
and the logic of your game?
And how is that going to make
someone feel while they're
playing your game?
Are you talking about
the style, the musical
and the visual style of your
game and how things move,
how things animate, and
how things [INAUDIBLE]
the things you hear?
Or are you talking more about
the fictional elements--
what's going on in
the sort of storyline?
All these three things
are going to work together
to create the
aesthetic of your game.
And all these things
need to work together
for your final project.
So I want you to be
thinking very, very
hard about what's the fiction of
the games that you're creating.
Is it being set in a real world
actual city, an actual named
city?
Is it kind of like an
abstraction of a city
in a certain part of the world?
Is it not a city at all?
Maybe you're playing
as the whole world?
Maybe you're playing as a
completely different planet,
and you're trying to get
through your learning that way.
Is it about a family?
Is it about an individual?
Is it about an entire town
council or something like that?
Style is something that you
have to leverage in order
to take advantage of
whatever strengths
you happen to have in your team.
If you have really good artists
or a really good musician,
you're going to take
advantage of that.
But you don't want
to do anything that's
going to sort of show
the assets that you
don't have a lot of
control over as being poor.
You want everything to be kind
of a matching even standard.
So for instance, if you did a
game that has mostly pixelated
8-bit style graphics,
and all of a sudden,
this vector art shape
comes in, you better
have a really good reason
for that thing to be there,
or a photograph shows up in your
game or something like that.
You better have a
really good reason
why you're throwing in two very,
very different visual styles
in there.
You can make it work.
But you need to be able to
think very, very hard about how
you're going to make that
work-- even things like what
your cursor is going to be.
And of course, how's that
going to work with your system,
right?
If your game is about a dire
situation-- floods are coming
in or something,
there's an epidemic--
and you put everything in
kind of nice, sunny, tropical,
everyone's at a beach
kind of a setting,
well, you can sort of do this
like weird subversive thing.
But then you have to be
very, very conscious.
It might be a little
bit easier for you
to just use a
visual that actually
supports the kind of game play
that your game actually has.
If the game is
about feeling tense,
use visuals that
also communicate
this sense of feeling tense.
There are games like-- how many
of you have played Tropical?
A couple of hands out there.
How about SimCity?
Who's played SimCity?
OK, a few more hands.
So what's the difference
between Tropical and SimCity
from someone who's
played Tropical?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The flavor is
completely different.
PHILIP TAN: The what?
STUDENT: The flavor.
Tropical is overall kind of
various Caribbean [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: There's a tropical
sort of equatorial setting,
as opposed to SimCity, which is
this very, very urban probably
temperate climate.
In one game, you're the mayor.
In another game, you're
set up as a dictator.
And the kinds of things
that you do in Tropical
are supposedly things that
are very similar to SimCity,
like building and zoning
and constructing up
your little island.
But at the same time, you also
have to do sort of dictatorial
quashing your resistance kind of
things, which you don't usually
do in SimCity.
But it's set in this
kind of very idyllic
tropical sunny environment.
And developers of
that game are usually
trying to play that for laughs.
It's like, yeah,
you're a dictator.
But you're not really
that evil compared
to some of the real
atrocities that you've
seen in tropical dictatorships
in the real world.
And so they're trying to use
the visuals to get across
that you're kind of
this comic dictator.
I can certainly
imagine a game that's
a lot more about real dictators
of small island nations.
And that will probably
be a lot more--
the visuals will probably
not be quite so cheery.
Even though it
might be sunny, it
will probably show
a little bit more
of the grit of what it's like
to live in a very humid and very
muggy and rainy place,
and try to play that
up so that that aesthetic works
with how the game play actually
is going to work.
So I should expand on that.
So we talked a
little bit about how
these things work on their own--
fiction, system, and style.
But in between, there
are sort of these domains
of game development,
which are going
to draw from both of them.
How a player interacts with the
system and the visual feedback
they're going to get from
that in the user interface
is going to also affect how
they feel about your game.
And it's going to
affect that aesthetic.
The way a certain
character has a theme song,
for instance-- this
one character who's
been lurking in the
background, and you've always
heard the theme kind
of in the background.
Then they show up in front.
And then suddenly it has a full
orchestration of their song.
Things like that are how style
and fiction work together,
this particular character's
theme, whether it's
Gollum, or the theme of one
of the big cities in Lord
of the Rings, or
something like that.
And of course, the level
design of your game itself
both have gameplay
implications and sort
of fictional implications.
A post-apocalyptic racing game
looks very, very different
from, say, a Formula One
modern-day racing game,
or a horse racing game.
And that's going
to not only change
the way how the game looks.
It's also going to change
the way how the game plays.
Is there debris on the track?
Is everything very dusty?
Is everything highly
polished and very clinical,
for instance?
And of course what
your characters can
do in an environment-- if you
say someone's a ninja, then
I expect this character
has ninja-like abilities.
Is this, oh, you're a ninja,
and you kind of punch people
in the face in sort of
one on one fisticuffs?
And it's like,
that's not a ninja.
You're thinking of
something else there.
Maybe you shouldn't call
that person a ninja.
So we've looked a
little bit at Sissy's.
I want to show a
couple of other games
that I feel do really, really
nail a cohesive aesthetic
on a very low budget.
And just for the
sake of time, I think
I'm just going to bring them
up without asking people
to come down and play.
But how many people have
played Thomas Was Alone?
Just about five people, OK.
Oh, there we go-- OK, it
was just loading up, cool.
So this is a game that's
mostly about rectangles.
There we go.
NARRATOR: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm glad I'm not
making you play this.
Because this is really
giving me a crick in my neck.
NARRATOR: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: OK, I'd like to
show you a little bit more.
But I find the
contrast on that screen
is a little bit too
low to actually see
what the level is like.
But it's pretty much
all geometric objects.
They're not all at right angles.
Not everything in the
game is a rectangle.
And you saw some of the water
kind of had some texture to it.
But it's pretty much all
flat shaded polygons.
The majority of the game is
all flat shaded polygons.
What in that very brief
clip that you saw sort of
gives you a sense of what
the developer of the game
wanted you to feel
about the game?
What were some of the elements?
What were some things that
were working in that game?
STUDENT: There's a
lot of empty space.
And it sort of adds to the
environment of being alone.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
you're very, very small
in the screen compared to
the rest of the screen.
STUDENT: The music also
gives that same impression.
But it's not too depressing.
Because you've got this
sort of story quality,
like [INAUDIBLE] 0.8.
So presumably you're
going to get to the part
where he's not
alone, or whatever.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, yeah,
it's Thomas Was Alone, not
Thomas Is Alone.
STUDENT: Also, I
haven't played it.
PHILIP TAN: No, you are making
some very logical assumptions
about this game,
which are actually
entirely true about this game.
Eventually, you find other
cubes, rectangles actually.
All right, and so that's
the way how the music works
to sort of set
the tone of, yeah,
it's kind of melancholy, but
not completely depressing.
You've got a bit of a beat.
What else?
I can't remember if you
mentioned the voice acting.
But what's that
doing to the game?
First of all, who's speaking?
Is it the cube?
STUDENT: Some external narrator.
PHILIP TAN: Some
external narrator, yeah.
So that's this.
And what does that imply?
What does that tell you
about what this game is
trying to get you to feel?
What comes to mind?
Hmm?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: Say what?
STUDENT: It's a story.
PHILIP TAN: That it is a story.
This is actually more of
a narrative based game.
STUDENT: It makes you
fell sort of isolated,
like you're being spoken
to by something far away,
almost nonexistent, and
you're sort of by yourself.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm,
so I think there's
a little bit of the game that
you're kind of being observed
by this third party that's not
actually part of the story,
but is narrating the
story of this rectangle.
So you're alone, but
not exactly, right?
There is this third
party there, which
is there to tell your story.
And somehow, this story
is going to go places,
as suggested by the music,
but also as suggested by some
of the things that he says.
He makes mental
notes for the future,
even though the mental notes
are kind of a silly one.
That implies there
is a future, right?
Yep?
STUDENT: It makes you feel
empathy for the character,
even though he's
just a rectangle.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, yeah.
Actually, let's talk
about that rectangle.
What does the rectangle
do when it jumps?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: Hm?
STUDENT: It gets thinner.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, it gets
a little squash and stretch
animation there.
For something that's really
just four right angles,
it's actually
remarkably expressive
when it actually
does a single job.
It gives you the sense
that this thing is not
an inanimate geometric object.
This thing is alive.
This is an organic
square, or rectangle.
OK, so we've gone
through a couple of ways
how this game achieves its
sort of aesthetic quality.
Let me see what my next
slide was going to be.
All right-- oops, darn it.
There we go.
I'm hitting the space bar.
Whenever you see a
big circle radiate,
that's me hitting the space bar.
What does that even say?
Oh jeez, OK.
OK.
OK, so I'm going
to quit that game.
So let's talk a
little bit about that.
First impressions?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] panel.
You have the whole
fish-eye thing
through the tube thing,
kind of like weird pixels.
And you also have this
guy going down the screen.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, so there's sort
of a vertical hold jittering
going on.
And actually, it
kind of doesn't look
like it's a flat screen, right?
It looks kind of--
STUDENT: Yeah, I kind of said
the old school kind of screen
with the fish-eye kind of thing.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, a
little tube shape to it.
Yep, that's a good one.
What else?
That's developed by
one guy, by the way.
STUDENT: You hear him
breathing the whole time.
So it kind of makes you
feel claustrophobic,
like you're in a small space
looking at this monitor.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm,
yep, so the fact
that you can hear your
own breath sort of
gives you an impression of
the space around you, which
is simultaneously
really, really small
and really, really
large at the same time.
You're in this
tiny little thing,
but there's this huge
world outside of there.
What else?
Is there any music?
STUDENT: I didn't get
what the objective was.
But it kind of
sounded [INAUDIBLE]
kind of space ship or something.
You're an astronaut in some
kind of spaceship or something,
and you're trying
to search for air.
PHILIP TAN: Yep.
So let's say, OK,
air is important.
And there's a lot of things
that remind you of that, right?
You have the breathing sounds.
You have the things
in the world that
are sort of [INAUDIBLE]
that you can pick up.
There's a little oxygen meter.
I'm not so sure if
all of you saw that.
There's a little oxygen meter
that's constantly running down.
And the sound of your
breathing changes
depending on how much
oxygen you've got,
or if you pick up an air pocket.
Then you can breathe.
What else?
OK, so you said space ship.
And a few people
said space ship.
What else gives
you the impression
this might be a space ship?
Because the game never tells
you that you're in a space ship.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: Hm?
STUDENT: I actually
thought it was underwater
instead of a space ship.
PHILIP TAN: It
could be underwater.
So what's the evidence for each?
Yeah?
STUDENT: So for underwater,
whenever you press space bar,
it kind of looked like
a radar sort of pulse.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, It's
kind of like a sonar ping,
which is something you'd
expect to do underwater.
What are things that remind
you of space in this game?
I would argue that-- oh, yeah.
STUDENT: Some of the
objects on the screen
look like they could
be stars [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, they look
like constellations, right?
STUDENT: There's that issue when
you're trying to turn around
you had to kind of stop.
And it almost seemed
like [INAUDIBLE] thruster
or some kind of [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, yeah, there's
a lot of inertia in changing
your direction, yeah.
Apparently there is an
answer on whether it's
space or underwater.
I don't actually know
the answer to that one.
But they're both
plausible conclusions
from actually nothing that
the game explicitly tells you.
All of that you derive from
hints, from the aesthetic.
But because the game kind
of works together really,
really well on the game
mechanics of running out
of air and the visual
representation of having
this old school monitor, as well
as the sound of you breathing
and everything that you kind of
know about what it's like to be
in a situation where air
is important, which implies
certainly not walking around
on the ground somewhere.
Or if you are, you might be on a
different planet, or something.
And what you know
about inertia gives you
this impression, this very,
very deep kind of world
that you can sort of make
theories about and imagine
where you might be
without the game actually
having to tell you any of that.
So that's a game where I feel
it's really, really successful
in getting that across.
This next one I'm just
going to play a demo.
This is Defcon.
It's kind of like a
real-time strategy game,
only on a sort of
global thermonuclear war
kind of scale.
Oops.
Screen-- here we go.
Is this 1,280 by 800?
I think my screen
resolution changed on me.
Yeah, when I tried to
fix that problem earlier,
the screen resolution
changed on me.
That doesn't matter.
I'll switch it to
something else.
Mostly, this is fine.
So I'm just going
to play a demo.
This is just a
game that you see.
This is as if the
game is just playing
against itself-- AI versus AI.
If anyone has seen-- how many
of you have seen War Games?
OK, wow, OK.
It's Matthew Broderick,
is that right?
And this is very much
inspired by that.
And the idea, of
course-- actually, I'm
not going to tell you
beyond what I just said.
I want you to start
calling out things
that you sort of think work
aesthetically about this game.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm going to move the
camera around, too.
This is an actual
game that you're
watching right now being
played with the AI playing
against itself.
Just call out stuff that
strikes you about this game.
STUDENT: The type face is
very nicely apocalyptic,
like all angles and-- I don't
really know how to explain it,
but it feels good.
PHILIP TAN: It's
stark, if nothing else.
There's a certain amount
of brutishness about it,
but also very technological.
It's not just like
hewn out of rock.
It's not that kind
of brutishness.
STUDENT: It's technological,
but it looks very old school.
It's very much like
a radar screen.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
not necessarily even
year 2000, right?
This seems like a much
older aesthetic, something
from the '80s maybe, Cold War.
Scroll over to something
a little bit closer.
No one's in America.
This is continental war.
What else?
What song is this?
Does anyone recognize the music?
STUDENT: Does anybody hear
anything other than music?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: Thunder?
STUDENT: Is it thunder?
STUDENT: It's this explosion.
PHILIP TAN: Where do you think--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: It's a little
[INAUDIBLE], really soft.
Where are you?
Where are you supposed to be
while you're playing this game?
STUDENT: War room.
PHILIP TAN: In a war
room underground,
several miles
underground, maybe.
It's a disturbing game.
The music-- I believe
it's all classical music.
But it's heavily filtered
through a lot of audio filters,
giving it a sort of a reverb
effect in the sort of sense
that you might be hearing this
inside a small enclosed space.
There's a little cassette player
inside your bunker somewhere.
So besides the font,
what about the UI?
What about the UI seems
to be-- in the way
how the units are represented?
Like those ships-- are
those ships life-size?
They're not, right?
They're not the size of
several cities put together.
These are some abstract
representations.
These are sort of army pieces
that you're moving on a board,
only it's a digital board,
that represent armies that
are out there in
the water or flying
through the air, squadrons
that are flying through the air
somehow.
So I'm going to quit now.
So Defcon is, again,
a very small team,
I think less than five people.
At least they were
less than five people
when they made Defcon.
Now they're making other games.
It was one of the
first successful games
by Introversion, which is the
name of the indie developer
that did this.
And yeah, they explicitly stated
that this is very much inspired
by War Games the movie.
It's about global
thermonuclear war.
It's about
specifically the movie
that was done in the '80s.
So it's very much about what
global thermonuclear war would
have made sense in the '80s.
Obviously, the
graphic representation
of what you see in that game
is a little bit higher end
than what you would normally
have had in the '80s.
But they're trying to sort
of not necessarily represent
things realistically, but sort
of how things as Hollywood
might have seen it.
And even the
marketing of the game
says-- I believe it's,
"Everybody dies," or something
like that.
And you can't really
win that game, right?
This is what the packaging
of this game looks like.
I think if you go
to [INAUDIBLE],
this is what it looks like now.
Uplink is another game by them.
It's worth checking out.
It's a game about hacking.
And if you look at that,
you'll see all the same sort
of '80s influences.
But it's not about launching
missiles at each other.
It's about breaking
into bank accounts
and changing your school
grades and things like that.
Finally, this is
a game I actually
do want people to play.
So who hasn't played Aaaaa!?
All right, I want a volunteer
to come down and play this game.
Come on down.
NARRATOR: Dejobaan
Games and Owlchemy Labs,
two lovers entwined
in an awkward embrace.
PHILIP TAN: This is
from Boston, by the way.
[ROBOTIC VOICE]
STUDENT: Jump?
PHILIP TAN: Go for it.
What can you--
STUDENT: Stage-- I
don't know, [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: Hit Unlock.
Oh.
STUDENT: Oh, bye.
PHILIP TAN: Just try-- OK.
That one?
Try it.
Yeah, OK, then hit Play.
OK, so the basic
idea of this game
is it's a base
jumping simulator.
So use WASD to jump off
the side of a building,
and then just fall.
NARRATOR: Checkpoint.
PHILIP TAN: Try not
to hit anything.
STUDENT: Shit.
PHILIP TAN: But try to get as
close to things as possible,
because that's how
you get points.
Oh, something [INAUDIBLE].
Ouch.
Is this in Endless mode?
STUDENT: Ah, I don't know.
PHILIP TAN: This
seems like it is.
STUDENT: No.
NARRATOR: Checkpoint.
STUDENT: Sorry, controls
are really light.
PHILIP TAN: OK, try
hitting space bar.
Oh, no, no, no, not yet.
STUDENT: Oh wait, oh no.
PHILIP TAN: It's cool.
It's fine.
All right, now try to land
in that little circle,
little red circle
behind that building.
Yep.
STUDENT: Come on.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
try landing there.
You did it.
OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PHILIP TAN: OK, I'm going
to turn the volume down.
What's working for
this game's aesthetic?
Did I see a hand back there?
Yeah, right there.
STUDENT: We're all
really used to games
with cylindrical coordinates
through a camera.
And this game appeared
to have it be the case
that as you look down, one
can then rotate your camera.
It really felt like you're
looking straight down.
And so we're very used to
having cylindrical coordinates.
PHILIP TAN: Mhm, yeah.
This is a game that uses sort
of WASD first person controls.
Only first of all,
you're not carrying a gun
and looking around like that.
You're pretty much doing
this for the entire game.
So you're always kind of
rotating around your center.
So that's a
systemic-- essentially
how the controls work.
STUDENT: Checkpoint restart
happened really, really
fast when you screwed up.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, yeah, so it's
like, survive to this point,
get to the next checkpoint.
And things are actually
flying past you
at a pretty high rate as well.
What else?
Music?
Art?
Storyline?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: I think
the music-- does
it start the moment your foot
leaves the first building?
I think there are
some levels where
it does that, where the
music only starts the moment
you jump off the building.
It's like, you can stay
on top of the building
as long as you want.
But nothing happens.
And then as soon as you
jump off, the music starts.
So it's like, all right, now
you're doing something that you
should feel excited about.
So we're going to play
this exciting music at you.
STUDENT: You can hear the
air while you're falling.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, there's a very
strong sort of rushing sound.
And you're getting
other UI sounds as well.
Those are the things that
are actually giving you
points, getting close
to other buildings.
And so there's some
visual feedback.
STUDENT: The game menu before
it starts is really confusing.
There was just way too much.
I don't think that
was working at all.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, the thing is
I've played a bit of this game.
So it normally directs
you to the first thing
that you can click
really clearly.
And then at some
point of time, it
stops leading you
to a linear path.
So you've got this whole
grid of different things
that you can do to choose one.
So admittedly, the
game UI may not
achieve what it's trying to do.
But what do you think
it's trying to do,
even if it fails at it?
It's sort of like, here's
this ridiculous grid
of all of these different
things that you can do.
But maybe some of them are
unlocked, or some of them
are still locked and some
things are still locked out.
What's the point of showing
you all these things
that you can't do?
STUDENT: Try and motivate
you to unlock them
so that you can do them.
PHILIP TAN: Right,
this whole idea
is that-- it's the
same idea in Zelda.
Sometimes you see this
heart in a location
which you know that you
can't actually get to yet.
But the whole point of that is
to make you want to get there.
And that's what the unlock
system in this game, I believe,
is trying to do.
It wants to give you an
incentive to keep playing.
Because there's all
this other content
that you haven't seen yet.
But you kind of have a
clue that it's out there.
At the beginning of
the game, there's
a little narration actually
that you may not have caught.
It says, the city of Boston
has outlawed base jumping,
so this whole idea
that what you're doing
isn't actually sanctioned
by the authorities.
And eventually, you get
these commands later
where you can flip off
people while you jump off,
unless they happen
to be your fans.
And then you give
them a thumbs up.
So there's a sense that what
you're doing isn't advisable.
This is not supposed to be
just how the future looks like.
Even in this weird future where
you have these mega skyscrapers
that go all the way into space,
this is still not a good idea.
But you're going
to do it anyway.
That's what this game is about.
So it's a 3D game.
This one was done
in Unity, actually,
although it was on port from
a game that wasn't originally
developed in Unity.
So you think of the
very first version,
which is just called
AaaaaAAaaaAAAaaAAAAaAAAAA!!!--
A Reckless Disregard
for Gravity.
Is that right?
Yeah.
That game only runs on Windows.
And all the versions
that have come since then
have all run on
multiple platforms.
Because they were
developed on Unity.
STUDENT: Including Oculus Rift.
PHILIP TAN: Including Oculus
Rift, an Oculus Rift version
of that game.
You can imagine how
that would work.
Anyway, so something that
I want to end on today--
there's a second
presentation very quickly.
Actually, you know what?
I've been talking for an hour.
Let's take a quick break.
And we'll come back
in 2:15, 10 minutes.
All right, let me
see, am I on mute?
OK, so what I'm
going to do now is
I'm going to have
your groups actually
have a discussion about what you
want your game mechanics to do.
And the reason for
this is because I
feel that a lot of you
probably are decently equipped
to talk about what you want your
story lines and your characters
or your art style or your sound
design to achieve in your game.
And the reason for that is
we've seen a lot of movies.
We know how we react to music.
We realize what visuals have
on sort of human emotion.
But I'm not sure if you've
had this discussion yet
in your team about what you
want your mechanics to do
aesthetically.
What kind of
experience do you want
to generate for the player?
So really, it's what you want
everything in your game to do.
But right now, I'm asking
you to do a discussion
about what you specifically
want your games to do.
I'm going to throw
some words at you
to help you be able to frame
these ideas inside your team.
First is that, is this a game?
How many of you feel like
you're making a game that's
kind of about strategically
outwitting the game system,
being smarter than the
computer, basically,
or being smarter than
the game designer, that's
how you win the game?
How many of you feel
like your game is really
about some random thing
happens, and now you
have to deal with it?
OK I see a couple, a few,
hands out there, maybe.
And some of you don't
know where your game
falls in that spectrum.
Of course, it could be
a bit of both, right?
A French writer named
Roger Caillois came up
with a categorization of what
these different kinds of game
play could be termed.
And he came up
with Agon and Alea.
Alea, some of you, if you've
ever studied Latin or Roman
history or anything,
might recognize it
from alea lacta est,
which is, the die is cast.
So that word comes from dice.
And it sort of represents
games of chance.
And Agon is a little
bit more about conflict.
It's about usually person
versus person conflict.
But in case of
games, it's just kind
of like competitive
contests of skill.
Basically how well can you
deal with this challenge
that's put in front of you?
Caillois goes on and describes
this as, this is sort of ludus.
This is the ludic
kind of play where
you're sort of playing--
it's very specific to what
games are all about.
There are other forms
of play out there
in the world that
don't necessarily
have anything to do with games.
A game isn't required to
have one of these things.
But for the most
part, what Caillois
claims is that these
kinds of actions
are the things that
really, really sort of
set games apart from other kinds
of play, this Agon and Alea.
But then there's-- what
else is there in play?
There's paidia and
ilinx, which are, again,
words that I don't necessarily
expect you to remember.
But here are words that
might be a little bit easier
to recollect, the sense of
being someone that you are not,
mimicking something that you
might fantasize in being,
or that you're being
asked to perform.
Are you a person on
the run from zombies?
Are you a military soldier?
Are you a detective?
Are you an assassin, a
scoundrel, that sort of thing?
You're being asked
to play that part.
Are you a town hall mayor?
Whereas vertigo, it's about
the sort of physical sensation
of playing the game.
And when it comes
to digital games,
usually that's one of the
things that digital games
have the biggest problem.
Unless you're doing something
like Dance Dance Revolution,
where you're actually having
to play the game as a full body
or a Kinect thing.
But even games like
Aaaaa!, we were
describing a game that's
very much trying to give you
this sense of physical motion.
So they're trying to
sort of conjure up
this sort of bodily freedom,
even if that freedom
necessarily means
a loss of control,
to sort of give you a
pleasurable experience.
And you get that in
other kinds of play.
How many of you
played that game where
you go around a baseball
bat with your head down,
and then you have to walk?
No one does this?
That's my favorite game.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP TAN: Yeah, you get
yourself as dizzy as you can.
Sometimes you look
up and you spin.
down and you spin.
And then you try
to make your way
across to the other
side of the finish line.
And that's like
literal vertigo, right?
So we've got these different
kinds of sensations
that this one series has already
described, and probably not
everything that games
can possibly do.
But they're kind of, in one way
of describing it, kinds of fun.
There is the sort of
competitive test of skill.
There is the, does
fortune favor you today?
Are you feeling lucky right now?
Do you want to press your luck?
Do you get to be
somebody else and live
through that experience?
Or do you just get to be in
a sort of physical situation
that you haven't been?
These are all different things
that your game mechanics
can achieve.
What I'd like to describe is
like the stuff on the right
is the stuff that sort of
puts you into the moment.
This is where you're being
asked to spontaneously react.
Can you think like a mayor of a
city, or president, or monarch?
Can you react in a
way as if buildings
were flying towards you
at 200 miles per hour?
Whereas everything on the right
is what we typically described
as the structure of the games.
You've been experimenting
with this in your prototypes
since day one.
But there's also kind
of the differences
between the decisions
that you get to make
and the things that kind
of just happen to you,
and you get to react.
So I like to describe the stuff
at the bottom as kind of fate.
This is the fate that you have.
Buildings are going
to fly into your face.
And you kind of need
to be able to then make
decisions to be able to
just deal with that reality.
Or fate being, well, the dice
is going to show what it is.
But the test of
skill is the part
where you get to
decide what you're
going to do given
that you know the odds
and that you know what kind
of actions that you can take.
So right now, in
your teams, what
I'd like you to do is actually
have a discussion about given
your prototypes that
you've developed so far--
I don't think we're
doing a test today.
We're doing tests
on Monday, right?
So what do you want
your prototype on Monday
to try to achieve?
It could be any
combination of this.
It could be all of it.
But I would like you to have
that discussion in your team,
just maybe 15 minutes?
Yeah, that's plenty of time.
And then what we're
going to do is just
do a very quick report
back about where you think
your team-- just one person
from each team will come down
and tell us, what are
the things that you think
you want your game
mechanics to achieve
in your prototype on Monday, OK?
15 minutes.
That will get us to
basically about 2:40.
All right, so go right ahead.
I'll just leave that up.
[BACKGROUND CHATTER]
STUDENT: So our game,
as it is right now,
you're basically playing
like a child or an animal.
We haven't decided.
And you're basically
going to go around
town figuring out this mystery.
So you're kind of playing
like a detective type story.
So based on the
slide, ours is more
like structure and decision.
So it's going to be
sort of a competition
against the computer where
you're trying to figure out
this mystery of what's
causing cholera,
or what's causing people
to be sick, actually.
You won't know
that it's cholera.
So yeah, that's basically
where our game stands.
PHILIP TAN: OK, all right, cool.
Thank you.
A very analytical
detective game that you're
working towards-- that's for the
prototype and tests on Monday.
Who's next?
Come on up.
STUDENT: Hi, we're Snap.
So we're planning on making a
very competition heavy game.
Because you're
going to be playing
with a bunch of other people.
So for Monday, we want
to have that competition
structure in place so that
we can see how it works.
We're also adding a
little bit more fiction
to Snap, which is very abstract.
And so we're going to later
on test how that works out.
But for now, it's
just really going
to be the basic competition of
the game that you've played.
PHILIP TAN: OK, all
right, thank you.
STUDENT: So for
Heatwave, we're mainly
going to focus on
originally decision,
deciding who you're
going to help
and how long you're going
to try and convince them
to drink some
water or go inside.
And there's also going to
be a small aspect of fate.
Because you can spend 10 turns
trying to convince a person
to go inside.
And at the end of
the 10 turns, they
say, no, I don't want
to talk to you anyone.
I'm not going inside.
So decision and fate.
PHILIP TAN: OK, cool, thank you.
STUDENT: Our team is working
on forecast based financing.
So because we're about
planning for disasters,
our game is pretty
heavy on chance.
But what we want to
teach the players to do
is to use planning
and forecasting
in order to reduce the effects
of that chance and sort of gain
valuable skills in
mitigating that.
PHILIP TAN: All right.
So it's very much on the
right side of this screen.
OK.
STUDENT: Hi, so we're
the other cholera group.
And we decided to create
a simulation based
game where there
are many villages,
and they have their
own water source.
And we have cholera
as some sort of entity
that can sort of
spread from village
to water to other villages.
And pretty much every village
has their own population.
They have their
own infection rate.
And what you are, you are
pretty much some sort of person
who really has a lot
of power and wants
to fix this cholera outbreak.
So this game focuses a
lot on decision making,
because you have many
different ways to try
to fix this problem--
either short term using
simple purification systems to
launch for waste management.
But this game also
has a lot of chance.
Because obviously, these
things aren't 100% efficient.
There's going to
be some failures,
going to be some breakdowns.
What we want to
focus on right now
is to make sure that we can
get our villages to have
their own sort of
parameters, make sure
that the cholera-- we have some
way of representing cholera
and how they spread to
all the other villages.
PHILIP TAN: Cool, thank you.
Is that all the teams,
or was there one more?
That's pretty much it.
OK, just a quick thing, so a
couple of thoughts-- one thing
that you should be
trying to figure out
as you work on your
prototypes is to what extent
the decision making,
which came up
with a lot of the
different groups,
going to be reacting to things
that you hadn't anticipated,
versus crafting
a long term plan.
The stuff that you deal
with on the short term
is going to go very
heavy on this side.
And it's going to
play a very big part
in making someone feel
like the kind of person
that you want to feel,
whether you're a big decision
maker or an individual
on the ground.
The long term plan part of
it is really more game-y.
You're really thinking more as
someone who's playing the game,
rather than someone who's
actually living the game.
And you can also
decide that's more
what you want people
to be going for,
especially games
that have to deal
a lot with planning for chance.
Now, just because you have
random numbers in your game,
and probability
rates and everything,
doesn't necessarily mean that
your game is all about chance,
even though you have these
things in your system.
Because if what chance
in your game really means
is that there is a certain rate
at which certain things are
going to happen, then
really that's just a rate.
That's something that
you can plan for.
You can just expect
every 10 turns,
you're going to get
three outbreaks.
That's how the numbers
are going to break down,
even though you don't know
exactly when those rates are
going to be.
And if your game is where every
single one of those times where
chance hits is really
catastrophically or really,
really beneficial,
then you've got
to get more of a game of chance.
If it's the sort of thing like
a certain number of these things
are going to happen
at a given rate,
and you just have to plan for
that rate, that is, to me, not
really chance anymore.
It's more about that
skill based test
of whether you can plan well.
So again, always
keep in mind, what
do you want your
game to feel like,
while you're trying to figure
out whether your simulation is
right, whether your facts are
right, whether this is actually
what happens with the
diseases or the catastrophes
that you're dealing with.
Also keep in mind this is
what you want your game
to feel like.
Make sure that's also informing
how you're designing your game
mechanics and your art
style and your story
line and your
characters and so forth.
That's what I've got to say.
PROFESSOR: So administratively
for Monday, we
have a lecture in the morning
about games for learning.
Then we're going
to do play tests.
And then at the
end of play test,
we're going to do the
two minute presentations,
so that when you're play
testing, even though we heard
a little bit about
what your games are,
we're not completely-- we'll
still be a little naive when
you're playing your games.
We'll know exactly what's
going on within the games.
In that two minute
presentation, we
want to know a
lot about process.
So let us know how you got to
the point where you are now
and where you
think you're going.
I believe product backlogs
are due at that point, too.
So use your product backlog
as part of your telling us
what you're planning on
doing on your projects.
I know a few of
you have come to me
and asked me about certain
aspects of your projects
that might not be answered
by the resource materials
that we've given you.
So hopefully you've read
through the resources,
and you're finding some
of your answers there.
If there are any
questions you have
that are not being
answered by your research,
email that to videogame-bosses,
and we'll forward that along
to the clients.
I'm working to get them to
allow me to just give you
their email address so you
can contact them directly.
I'm still figuring
out who exactly
for each of those projects
that's going to be.
But that should be
solidified by Monday.
But yeah, things to look
out for that might not
be answered in your resources
are cultural sensitivity,
particularly because of who
your target audience might be.
So if you're doing
anything graphical,
if you're doing anything
representational,
really think hard about who it
is is playing the game, what
kind of cultural
background they have,
and how are you
representing it to them.
Are you doing it both
authentically and also
not patronizing them?
It's going to be a really
hard challenge for you.
We don't expect you to actually
solve it this semester.
We expect you to come
up with some ways
to figure out how you might
solve it in the future.
And that's kind of what we
want to hear about in some
of these presentations.
Or how are you solving
those kind of problems?
Any questions before we
let you go and let you
work in your teams?
STUDENT: Can you give us an
idea of how much time we'll
have in class to work with our
teams so we can better plan?
PROFESSOR: Hour and a half.
We went a little bit long
today, about 20 minutes long.
PHILIP TAN: That's all my
fault. I'm sorry about that.
PROFESSOR: Blame him, but
hour and a half basically.
If there's a guest lecture,
those tend to be an hour long.
And then that would
be two hours long.
If it's not a guest
lecture, we tend
to ramble, so hour and a half.
Also part of that is because
we start class at 1:10.
That kills some of the time.
So if you want to come
into class at 1:00
and be in your teams
and work in your teams,
and then we yell at you
to shut up, that's fine.
That's actually good.
You're using your time well.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah,
you come in at 1:00,
and then do a daily
scrub, and then you
are ready to start class.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
All right, so I'm putting
these materials up here.
And also a reminder,
the play test,
if we weren't really
specific about it,
we are expecting low
fidelity prototypes.
But it could be
digital or paper.
It's really whatever is
useful for you, that's
what we want to see tested.
[BACKGROUND CHATTER]